[Music]
when people think about ballet they
think something light jumps turns not
difficult
when people think about martial arts is
punching in the face blood broken nose
people screaming
knockouts but all dancers are fighters
and all fighters are dancers
[Music]
my name is george berkadze and i'm a
guest teacher at boston ballet
i am also a professional martial arts
fighter
i've been principal dancer in many
companies i travel all around the world
i've been doing ballet professionally
since i'm 11.
i start to dance because dance is very
important in my country georgia and
we're all dancers
i was bullied because i was young dancer
they were saying that i'm feminine it
was insulting
to protect myself being bullied i learn
martial arts
i am a black belt first degree in
brazilian jiu jitsu i'm black belt in
judo and i'm black belt third degree in
kyokushin karate most people think that
professional dancers and professional
fighters are very different but there is
more similarities between them
in ballet and in martial arts you want
to maintain your balance
in both you want to perform technique so
it looks beautiful and valid and cool in
martial arts
you're training every day to make your
execution excellent
martial art taught me how to control
myself good discipline and
make me a better martial artist
as a dancer nobody ever can tell me that
i'm weak and as a martial artist nobody
can tell me that you just beat people
you can't judge people by appearance
you never know
[Music]
you